denise raider nation back in action at
allegiant stadium for the season opener
monday night against the baltimore
ravens while home fans gearing up for
the big event city officials also making
sure that attendees stay safe madison
kimbrough live from allegiant stadium
with some details on what you need to
know
in just a couple of days fans will get
to experience their first monday night
football game experience of the 2021
season here at allegion stadium
in addition to it being the first home
game of the season it's also the first
since the raiders announcement of
mandatory vaccines for fans parking
continues to be a concern for visitors
as well as traffic but the key is to
prepare ahead of time and leave early i
spoke to county commissioner michael
naft who is confident in metro's
abilities and handling whatever
situation may arise urging people to
follow the rules on game day i've
received a briefing from our special
events lieutenant who has been in
contact with the organizers of a protest
at least one that's been publicized i
would hope that they would be respectful
and keep a distance acknowledging that
our officers on the front lines are just
trying to uphold the rules that are in
place metro will be in and outside of
allegiant stadium before during and
after the game
and a reminder allegiant is cashless
everything must be paid for by debit
credit or mobile payment and as for bags
clear bags are fine but there is a size
limit there also have bag checks
available but that's for a fee so
traveling light is really your best
option reporting live from allegion
stadium madison kimbrough 8 news now